technologies are changing our world forever, but not in ways you might expect.
For example, artificial general intelligence. Artificial general
intelligence, often referred to as AGI, is the concept of a machine with the
ability to understand, learn, and apply its intelligence to solve any problem,
much like a human being. Unlike narrow AI, which is designed for specific tasks, AGI
would have the capacity to handle a wide range of cognitive tasks and adapt
to new situations autonomously. Significant strides are being made in
AGI research by leading organizations such as OpenAI and Google DeepMind. One
approach is through deep learning and neural networks, which mimic the human
brain structure and function. Researchers are working on expanding
these models to handle more complex abstract tasks that go beyond pattern
recognition and data processing. Another interesting development is in the field
of reinforcement learning, where AI systems learn to make decisions by trial
and error, receiving rewards for successful outcomes. This approach is
seen as a potential pathway towards developing more general problem-solving
capabilities in AI. Looking into the future, the evolution of AGI could have
profound implications. If achieved, AGI could perform a wide range of tasks,
from complex scientific research and medical diagnosis to creative arts and
decision-making. We may arrive at a stage where AGI is capable of handling any
task that involves computer-related work, and it could potentially surpass human
intelligence in certain areas, leading to breakthroughs in various fields. AGI
could also lead to the development of more intuitive and versatile personal
assistance, capable of understanding and responding to a wide range of human
needs and preferences. In industry, AGI could automate complex tasks, leading to
significant efficiency gains. In time, artificial general intelligences may
have the capability to enhance their own algorithms and architectures, potentially
giving rise to super-intelligent AIs. These super-intelligent AIs could
possess intelligence that surpasses human capabilities by thousands or even
millions of times. Such advanced AIs hold the potential to create groundbreaking
technologies and change society in ways that are currently difficult to fully comprehend.